WE'LL BRING YOU MORE A
MORE INFORMATION FROM
IT WASN'T THAT VLEEAT, CAPITOL E
TO PHOA
IN JANS
6th CAPIRIOT.
RTQUOT ITHESE COMPANIES COMPLY H
CRO TURN OVER ATE RM THEY ARVIO
ECT R ABILIT
TO ITH STENIES STILL CHOOSE TO A
PU MOR
FORGET AND WILL STAND WITHTHEM .
RYAN, WHAT IS E COMMITTEE'ONSE I
IS NOTNGOW THR THEKECNN'S EXUS
REPORTING ON THE FACT THAT THEI
T THATHEIR IOINT THAT THEY NT T
ME
-U JANUARY 6 RRECTION.
THE COMMTE AFT
SENT OU
A HEY'RE NOT
TO BE TEE
TS OF JANU
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SK FOR THIS
RKITANTECHPAO GET ATERY NEEDO C.
E S DOES
SOMETHIN TS
E FLOWINFOIO COU
DOESHEN?XPECTED THAT THEREBE A R
SOMEAL
COULD BE -- WHS COULD
WAS ATION OF PERS RS
AND O STEP IN THE
IF YOU R ALISYN.
LEADERUTTINGT HAHE
THAT IEY T THESE
THIM
CONGSSL MME,
SS
NOW, T T
IA CPADED TO McCTHS
IS
E DEMO THING KERUCTING THIS
CONGRESS, AS
SAID THIOMETHING THAT THF JUST
THDOJ NON THAT
T W.D DEMO MBE THE
HOETOMTT TO THIS ANFER OM
EVIN MS
CONDUCT IN ALL OF
S POI OUT THAN McHY SAID OBTUSS
BUT HE T TO SAY ECT
OUT T AAD
AND HE SAID COULD FORCTHCOMPANS
AGEV WHAT
THAT LAW I
NOBLES, LUCKILY WE HAVE
L US ALL
AB.
YOU VERY MUCH.INN SENI
HOG.SO WHA PHONE RD
,
HE'S MAKIN UP.HERE'SO.
HET WORKS.ITE THE OPON
TH THESEPROVIDERS,, THEYT SUBPO.
AUNE SUBPOENAFOR ONE RECORDS A.
, THE LA E'S NOTHING TRY
HERE.
SMACK, TRYING TO THROW AY
WR I. W WHAT THE CMIISONE
RECORDS AND WHD KEVI
O BLOC BLOCK POTENTIALOM BEI, RI
THE RECORDE G TO
BE E COMMITTEE BECAUSE G TO GIV.
THEY'RE GO SYOU,
YOU STAR ATION.H MINUTOF WHA
AS A PCUTOR, AS AN
INVESTIGATOR YWH S WITH WHO AT H
CRITICALTALK PEOPLE.
EVIN McCARTHY, MAYBEIT'S JIMDANK
MEADOWS.
THAT RESULTS I
E THME ERS AROUND M.UST SO
LAWMERE TO SOME OF T CAPIL ER
COULD BE.D SEE THAT IN THOS
THTHCLEAR, THEY WANTS WHEN, MES
6th.
WHO DID YOEA YOU SPEAK ABOUT?
I THTHHAT'S GOT KEHYORRIED.
>> WD Y THIDT' AUSE REO BELATED
THIS IS ON THE CORE S HERE.
IS NOTIT.
LET'S REER, JIM JORD FOR  SAI G
TH 'S SEE IFY'FOR ATVEOT,
FO.
LEGAL N TTT
ONFOHIM?IS HE OBSTRUCTING JUIC
HAT  MO OBSTRUCT
JUSTICE OR IN THIS CASPREE
MAKE AOPRIATRE
GREE ICH
OFD THREAT IT WAA HR HAKASSUMINR
ZOPANIESTHAT SOUND THREAT.
LAWS.UST TURD EXERCISE MY LEGAL
E IS NW.
YOU CAN'T MAKE SOMETHING UP ANDR
T WILLE POLITICALLY EXPLOSIVE.